and developing tonight a potential tax
deal that would bring a movie studio to
the valley a news now reporter Brian
will on this story explaining the effort
lawmakers are making to get so many
pictures to come right here to Las Vegas
this piece of land could be the future
home of a movie studio which would mean
thousands of jobs for the valley Senate
Bill 496 introduced on Thursday by
Democratic state senator Roberta Lang
along with support from Howard Hughes
core and Sony Pictures would establish a
film tax credit infrastructure program
we have bipartisan support
um one from the minority leader in the
Senate so I'm excited about that and I
think that
um in the next few days next week is I'm
going to get more people to sign on to
the bill we'll get large bipartisan
support the bill would offer movie
studios like Sony Pictures tax credits
worth roughly 190 million dollars per
year and paid each year through 2043 the
annual limit to projects would be
extended to 15 million dollars and
projects could be eligible for tax
breaks up to 30 percent of total
production costs additional tax breaks
under the bill are for broader
television and other types of video
production also in the bill is an
educational building on-site partnership
with UNLV it means thousands of jobs it
means stabilizing our economy it means
creating a new industry that we won't
have to rely so much on on the casino
industry that we'll have something else
that we can lean on it's all in an
effort to bring more movie projects to
the valley this is one of two possible
locations for the development the other
being within the city of Las Vegas with
no address known yet reporting in
Southwest Las Vegas Brian will eight
news now